every billionaire has billion dollar
homes every billionaire except Elon Musk
known for turning a sofa in the Boca
Chica SpaceX office into his bed the
world's richest man took it to another
level when he announced Tesla's ten
thousand dollar sustainable unboxable
movable home wait what ten thousand
dollars unboxable what kind of home are
we talking about well you are about to
find out if you are remotely familiar
with the Tesla CEO you wouldn't be
surprised that he is building a
sustainable home the entire concept of
Tesla was built on the premise of
sustainability his incredible dream to
colonize Mars runs on the sole purpose
of giving Humanity another chance even
the Rockets he uses are built to be
reusable but while 15 million dollar
reusable Rockets sounds reasonable from
a rocket perspective a ten thousand
dollar unboxable home is just wild so
how did Elon go from overhauling the
tech space to completely disrupting the
real estate industry well it all started
with this tweet from 2020 at the height
of the pandemic Elon Musk made this
insane announcement I am selling almost
all physical possessions will own no
house at the time he owned seven houses
in the months that followed he had sold
six of them why well he couldn't find
the right buyer for a billionaire he was
really hell-bent on being homeless and
no one was sure what he was up to in
June of 2021 Elon Musk finally got his
wish he announced that he had found the
buyer he was looking for he had sold his
last house Elon Musk was officially
homeless this move while extreme wasn't
unlike Elon it was totally in line with
the kind of person he was I don't care
if Justine and the kids and I end up
living
and Justine's parents basement I'm gonna
make this happen
I mean this is the same guy who was
ready to move his family into his
father-in-law's basement to get Tesla
off the ground and this is the man who
had gotten close to bankruptcy so many
times it was becoming a habit to anyone
who didn't know him Elon Musk was just a
crazy person with a lot of money for
those who knew Elon Musk was crazy all
right and sure he had more money than
anyone should have but one thing that
set him apart from his peers was the
fact that whenever he took sacrifices
like this it was always because he had a
dream he was dying to bring to life in
this case that dream was a house like
none other the boxable story before
Tesla began flirting around with the
idea of making sustainable housing a
handful of small companies were already
in the business before Elon Musk began
dreaming of incredibly small incredibly
affordable and Incredibly sustainable
housing boxable existed
foreign
[Music]
close to achieving what Elon Musk would
eventually set out to achieve this
company which began in 2017 came into
the Limelight in 2021 a few months after
Elon Musk was declared technically
homeless he had to sleep somewhere and
the sofa in his Boca Chica office
couldn't cut it that is when someone
told him about boxable a 50 000 foldable
home that could be constructed in under
an hour despite the fact that the house
was basically a giant collection of Lego
pieces it pieced together like a real
house and it also had all the required
facilities a living area bathroom
bedroom kitchen as well as insulation
and energy saving lighting Elon was so
impressed that he indirectly endorsed
the company in this tweet he had
upgraded from his Boca Chica office to
the boxable condo in their parking lot
okay I'm kidding I can't tell if this
was built in their parking lot or not
eventually and as you would expect it
didn't take long for Tesla CEO to see a
future of sustainability in real estate
he took the basic idea of his box home
and improved on it he calls it the Tesla
tiny house the Tesla tiny home evokes
the same Vibe you get from a horse-drawn
Romani Caravan home it's simple it's
practical and you can haul it down with
your Tesla you wouldn't be wrong to say
that it looks like an unintegrated RV
but you would be wrong if you think that
it doesn't offer a lot more consider it
a more advanced version of an RV we're
talking jumbo Jets and spaceships here
right off the bat and like I stated
earlier the Tesla tiny house is centered
around self-sustenance and renewable
energy this is a theme we've seen across
all elon's products and the tiny house
is no different okay maybe the Tesla
flamethrower and Tequila don't make the
cut but you get what I mean for example
Tesla's powerwall and solar panels play
a massive role in the tiny house in fact
Tesla's solar panels have been Central
to elon's plans every time he dabbled in
the real estate industry in October of
2016 he acquired Solar City because he
was intent on bringing self-powered
homes to every homeowner these homes
were fully furnished with Tesla electric
vehicle Chargers solar roofs and Tesla
power walls to retain the energy for
future use the solar roofs in particular
were not just panels on asphalt shingles
they were custom-built solar tiles for
each sheet of roof this technique vastly
improved the efficiency of the roofing
system making it more durable than
regular tiles and introduced in energy
conducting system that could power the
entire house with ease so you can see
that in a way these e-homes heralded
tiny houses but there is a whole lot
that has been improved and a lot more
that we have skimmed over so let's cover
how elon's team optimized the solar and
power of the tiny home and how the
construction is way more Superior than
any mobile home on the planet solar and
power the Tesla tiny house is equipped
with six solar panel systems packed with
minuscule tiles for its roof these tiles
automatically tilt towards direct
sunlight during unfavorable weather
conditions like snow or a rainstorm this
allows the tiny house to make as much as
4.1 one kilowatts of energy which is
more than enough to keep the house
running but it gets even better because
once it begins Gathering the energy it
needs it immediately stores some of it
in Tesla power walls power walls are
basically batteries or inverters for the
home that store energy and disperse it
in the event of an outage or whenever
you want to conserve your electricity
consumption the power wall is one of
Tesla's most sought after Renovations
and its inclusion in the tiny home is
what sets it above your favorite RV now
you might be thinking solar energy is
good and all but can it actually do much
you would be shocked Tesla has managed
to ensure that the energy generated from
the panels can support daily home
activities which includes everything
from cooking on electric stoves to
ironing to covering basically any home
keeping device that requires electricity
the solar panel and powerwall package
are one of a kind and the company has so
much trust in its durability that a
25-year guarantee is placed on it
however the Cherry of all features is
The house's heating system system
because no matter how cold it gets
outside this tiny house will always
remain warm on its inside construction
now that we've spoken about the interior
it's about time we spoke about the
external structure of the tiny homes one
downside of Orthodox construction is
that the longer the building takes the
more materials degrade due to the
weather and other factors this has been
a huge block in getting the real estate
industry to take major leaps towards
affordability this is because of the
cost of labor per time as well as
unforeseen circumstances like
Replacements of materials affected by
these factors well for every problem it
is faced Tesla has managed to come up
with a solution and this solution they
found in concrete steel and EPS foam
after years of testing trial and error
these three materials have been found
worthy of withstanding degradation and
being the best for piecing together
these foldable homes all the parts are
fitted to laminated panels that form the
walls and roof and are coupled together
in a way that lets them fit into regular
size containers for shipping the
coupling and most of the manufacturing
take place in factories not unlike the
Tesla vehicles now although it may look
small on the outside everything about
the Tesla tiny house is the same as what
you get in traditional housing it can
fit a queen-size bed a washroom a studio
and kitchen appliances like a
refrigerator microwave stove and more
when ordering your tiny house you get to
customize its setup in 15 minutes and
you receive exactly what you ordered the
entire setup is controllable via a
single app installed on your smartphone
this app lets you see what is going on
when you're not at home control Power
and get notifications for information on
the power situation to make sure
whatever needs constant power in your
home remains safe practically and I've
been trying my best to avoid using this
word the Tesla tiny house is a smart
home show me an RV that can beat that oh
wait another thing to look out for in
this tiny house is the charging outlets
for Tesla cars it would be the mother of
all convenience is if you have a Tesla
vehicle and even if you don't which is
kinda suspicious you could basically
sell electricity to other electric
vehicle users now you can wake up to a
fully charged car courtesy of your house
the selling point of these electric cars
is not just in the Sleek design and the
fact that it's state of the art it's in
its integration kinda like the Apple
ecosystem the Tesla tiny house is
properly integrated into the Tesla
ecosystem of products it creates this
energy Loop where your tiny house is
powered by solar energy which in turn
Powers your electric car that can move
your tiny house around now it's time for
the big question when will the Tesla
tiny house be available at the moment no
one knows currently there have been
prototype showcases in Australia and
there have been promises of more before
the house is eventually slated for mass
production until then all we can do is
keep our fingers crossed but if you want
to keep up with more of Elon musk's
inventions and businesses check out some
of these other videos